well as i've been saying for about a
month and a half now
if there are going to be serious
criminal charges against the upper
echelon of the trump circle
i believe they are more likely to come
from the georgia investigation remember
that's the one where trump wanted votes
i need 11 000 votes give me a break that
one
then from what's going on with the
january 6 committee that's my opinion
now it could be wrong and indeed we are
getting a sign that there could be
trouble
in paradise rudy giuliani trump's former
lawyer republican senator lindsey graham
as well as trump's former lawyer john
eastman have been subpoenaed in the
georgia it's actually fulton county
grand jury probe rolling stone writes
the fulton county grand jury's probe
appears to be closing in on the former
president who pressured georgia's top
election officials to find the votes i
need 11 000 votes give me a break needed
to overturn the election
um they have slapped a bevy of subpoenas
on several figures tied to trump
including rudy giuliani lindsey graham
john eastman john eastman's that very
outrageous lawyer
who wrote the plan for how pence could
potentially overturn the results and
then was advised to get a criminal
lawyer
um by eric hershberg cleta mitchell
kenneth chesbro and jenna ellis all of
which were involved in trump's scheme to
overturn the election also received
subpoenas so too did senator lindsey
graham
the atlanta journal constitution notes
giuliani testified before georgia
lawmakers three times following the 2020
election and that the ludicrous
unfounded claims about election fraud
during that testimony has drawn the
interest of the grand jury remember rudy
was flying around the country
with flatulence and covid i'm not it's
just it's what it is i'm just telling
you what it is
um doing hearings where if i recall
correctly no one was under oath like
almost ever or maybe ever
and um he was making a fool out of
himself he was making a fool out of
trump it was crazy so rudy is the target
of a subpoena lindsey graham allegedly
called georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger to ask if he had the power
to toss out legally cast absentee
ballots uh so uh lindsay is being sucked
into it
and um
john eastman as well the subpoenas which
were issued yesterday come as the grand
jury has been hearing testimony from a
parade of witnesses
so there's a couple different things
going on here that i think are important
to consider
first of all
when i look at lindsey graham
lindsay to me seems like the exact type
of guy who will throw anybody under the
bus to save himself
rudy seems like the type of guy who
others throw under the bus and so far
that's the way it's worked out lindsay
has flip-flopped a dozen times now on is
trump good or bad
what was the deal with the 2020 election
it you might remember very early on the
morning of january 7th after midnight
roughly maybe just before midnight
lindsay gave the speech on the floor of
that house or senate don't remember
where they were convened at the time and
said it's time for it to end the
election is over and people looked and
said oh good what a mature guy but then
he walks that back and he says the
regularities this that the other thing
so lindsay is the prototypical guy of
i'll say whatever i need to say right
now to save my own ass
rudy has just been getting slapped
around by everybody trump yeah that they
all it's
and so everybody is kind of playing
their role um
the question about john eastman is an
interesting one eastman
he wrote this
seven point or however many points there
were plan
for how pence could
send the election back to the states
but he seemed to acknowledge based on
testimony given to the january six
committee i think that he sort of knew
it was bogus and then he was advised to
get a criminal lawyer because what he
was sort of suggesting
is arguably against the law uh very
clearly seems to be against the law so i
don't know what the direction will be
there now there have been many people
saying are they going to fight these
subpoenas are they going to ignore these
subpoenas well they'll do everything
they can to delay their appearances
but a contempt of court is different
than contempt of congress not showing up
when the january 6th committee wants you
to show up is one thing and that we've
seen some criminal referrals but not
showing up when you're subpoenaed by a
court is a different thing so my
expectation is they'll delay the
appearances as much as possible
and then they'll show up and
assert their fifth amendment right
to avoid self-incrimination
and um
i i don't know that you're really going
to see them in serious legal trouble but
we're going to follow it now uh the one
other aspect of this
is
people have been asking about
extradition
my understanding is that within the
within the us states extradite like if
uh you know rudy i don't know where rudy
lives now maybe he's in new york maybe
he's in dc i'm not sure
if um georgia calls new york and says
you gotta extradite rudy he's in
contempt of court
my understanding is new york does it
that new york will do it but we will
allow other lawyers to weigh in on that
as well i think this is the biggest
discount that any sponsor has ever
offered on the david pakman show this is
crush organics crush organics loves the
show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 percent off
their entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate ten dollars to the
last prisoner project that's a really
great non-profit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important
and it doesn't stop there anyone who
uses my code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 percent
off and a free jar of gummies or topical
cream and 10 bucks towards creating real
change in our justice system go to crush
organics dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below